[Music]
as Pete was saying I have a several too
many years working with data in a broad
range of data I started actually working
with industrial manufacturing data steel
production and then transportation data
city data telco data and quite a bit
with financial data and it was from each
one of the changes it was fascinating
diving into the data and getting getting
your heart hands dirty which I guess is
what the community here likes to hear
about a data but I want to start
explaining some of the shortcomings of
all the data that I worked with and
basically a though this data can solve a
number of very relevant challenge
challenges on each one of these
respective industries they fall pretty
short in solving some of the major
challenges that humanity has today so if
you look at humanity as a whole people
globally and I'm going to go through
some very very basic examples you know
if you look at food this is the number
of land that has been that is being used
year-over-year for food production in
order to feed humankind as you know
we're being very successful in food
production
not so much in food distribution but we
are producing more food than humanity
needs but this is at a high cost in
terms of environment so if we want to
continue increasing food production by
2050 there will be about between 9,000
10,000 of us here will need to double
food production from today to that year
because we need to feed the people but
we also need to feed the animals so if
we want to do that in a sustainable way
we basically have three options either
we go in plant in the Sahara or
we DeForest the Amazon basin or we find
new alternative seats in ways of a more
advanced ways genetically of producing
foods or we do what we're doing more
efficiently we use the land we are
already using more efficiently and
there's a lot of evidence to show that
this last option is preferred over the
first options and data is very relevant
in order to achieve it let's look at
another challenge here this is global
primary energy consumption so as you can
see not only it's going exponentially
like a most of the indicators that that
we're showing but it is also growing
along some of the lines we're not so
interested in growing like cold and
crude oil and natural gas because
there's like finite resources so we need
ways of managing much better not only
how that grows in order to use energy
more efficiently but also in the
distribution between different energy
sources so this is a huge challenge that
we have ahead not only at the level of
the production but also at the level of
the global distribution of the energy
another huge challenge that we're
struggling with is the management of
natural resources so what you see there
that's that's that graph shows a mixture
of forest gain for its loss but you have
loss of forest is inbred very worrying
along the equator which is where most of
the canopy is concentrated but you can
see on the other side that you have net
gain of forest in many of the developing
countries so there's a lot that there's
some positive indicators that if we
manage to to to arrange the production
and the use of land more efficiently
related with energy related with food we
can regain a forest production and we
need to manage this the thing is how do
we manage this and
kind of data what is the solution for
this so the the the the what I we know a
couple of things that whatever solution
to these huge problems there are a it
has to be global right we cannot have a
solution that's good in Spain but then
it doesn't work we're gonna have food
solution that is good at Spain that
doesn't work for the rest of Europe we
can't have regulations that finish in
any border because we know that in the
globalized world we have anybody will be
able to bypass the the regulation but
just jumping across the border we need
to we need to have that solution to be
global so we need to look at it globally
in a way what we need and we don't know
which is the right solution for each one
of those but it but at the very least
what we want to know is whether one
solution is better than the other one as
we don't doubt that creativity human
creativity will come up with many
possible solutions for all these
challenges I don't doubt about that but
what I'm not sure is how are we going to
cryed which ones are good and which ones
are not so good so in a way inside a
logic what we said is we need something
like a Fitbit for the planet that at the
very least we're measuring each one of
these solutions each one of these
policies as they are taking each one of
the changes and were able to tell this
is good this is bad in another to do
that we need to do it at a planetary
scale and there's many ways of doing
this we could we could send aerostatic
globes we could cover the planet with
drones we could have earth sensors every
10 meters to measure all this we could
empower our telephones to do more things
that they're doing but a that's not at a
planetary scale even if we have our cell
phones the land cover of the earth by
humans is very limited and a lot of
these things food production energy
production are happening where we are
not right in remote places so the reason
SATA logic was never intended to be a
satellite person it was a
company it was intended to be a
solutions company for these kind of
challenges turns out that satellites are
just great as remote sensors for acting
as a Fitbit of the planet the challenge
then was that satellites building a
satellite that took 1 meter resolution
imagery of the planet
ten years ago cost 650 million dollars
okay so the cost of opportunity of
having each one of those images and the
coverage of those images was just too
limited in order to have daily let's say
coverage of the planet at 1 meter
resolution you need hundreds of those
satellites so it simply does not scale
so we need to make satellites much
cheaper much lighter much smaller okay
because cost also is related with the
launching cost and weight has a lot to
do with that and if we manage to do that
we could scale that coverage we could
have images of the planet every single
day every single week and most
importantly if I manage to do a
satellite for this in a million and I'm
talking a thousand times improvement
from the previous version I reduce my
learning cycle and as you know with
technology the key is reducing your
learning cycle if you manage to do
anything any kind of experimental
environment anything which allows you to
learn faster then you enter into a cycle
that you really can do breakthrough
stuff right and you need to do all that
that reduction while preserving data
quality and what I mean by data quality
here is taking good 1 meter resolution
images because why 1 meter why not 10
meters for instance right now you have
free imagery of the world every 5 days
thanks to the Copernicus to Sentinel
satellites to the Copernicus
constellation or to Landsat data a
little bit lower resolution a but it has
10 meters 15 meters and the reason for 1
meter is 1 meter is the scale of human
beings
it's our scale we we live at 1 meter
scale you know our roads are this size
because
we are this size and our cars are this
size because we are this size in our
machinery and buildings and everything
we do our impact in the planet is in the
meter scale if we were one centimeter in
size probably would lead we would need
much higher resolution satellites than
we than we do now
so we did that and we currently have a
eight satellites in space and these are
sample this is sample image of here of
Barcelona at 1 meter resolution taking
bar satellites earlier earlier this year
and you can do Barcelona which is
heavily populated but on the other side
it's also heavily populated with sensors
so the value of doing Barcelona or any
other large city is not so important and
I'm sure that many of the data that most
of you guys work here be it
transportation uber lyft a kavithai a
global financial data can give a very
good image of what's going on in
Barcelona but not so good in in in West
Liberty Iowa right a where a lot of the
production of a in this case corn and
soy is taking place mostly production in
the United States that's the call the
Corn Belt in the United States and on
top of that what we did is in not only
he added a 1 meter resolution camera
what we did what's called a
hyperspectral 30 meter resolution camera
so hyperspectral and I'm mentioning this
because I'm going to show you examples
on computer vision on each one of those
sensors so you need to understand what
they do a hyper spectrum means that
basically our hyperspectral camera looks
over the visible scale plus the
near-infrared but instead of having
three different channels like we would
have it has 30 different channels that
looks into very narrow bands in a way
it's like have it looking at colors with
superpowers like where we see maybe the
same plant being having a green leaf a
hyperspectral camera would look that
that could be a a million shades of
green and thanks to those shades you
would know the health of the plant so
you can do a ton of nice things this is
Gambia
here for instance here in Gambia we're
looking at the presence of algae in the
rivers and the reason we're looking at
the presence of alga is because the
where those alga I live lives some tiny
snails and those snails are where these
parasites that giving Gambians huge
headaches because they're causing gastro
problems in children inhabit in these
are parasites that inhabit in these
snails they're transported by these
snails
so by looking at the alga you can
anticipate where this disease this
parasite disease will be spreading
because where you have huge growth of
alga you will have a higher probability
of that disease spreading in nearby
towns so so you already can see through
a very simple example looking this how
this new source of data can help address
some challenging problems and here just
just a curiosity example is we not only
do the images we also do video is that
not not so good video but what you're
seeing there all the time is Venice and
what I like that's Venice you know the
islands around Venice and so forth and
it was a first video we got so we're
proud of it not because of its quality
but because of its originality and
what's really interesting about this
video it gives you an idea of how fast
these satellites move in order to
capture the data the video as you've
seen it started shooting when the
satellite was over Moscow in it finished
shooting when the satellite was over
Cairo so when you have these two sources
of data the multispectral data and the
hyperspectral data you can address as I
said challenges along many different a
sectors a government sectors agriculture
infrastructure in many different ways
and what I'm going to show you one is
very concrete examples of the basis of
those challenges because you need to
build a solution for instance for people
whom I'll manage or remote very
expensive oil infrastructure it's really
expensive too
people their airplanes drones so doing
it remotely will save them a lot of
money but in doing that solution you
need to talk their language you need to
do something that will integrate with
their oilfield management systems and so
on but what underlies always these
systems right between the data and their
solutions is computer vision you know
machine learning computer vision image
processing so these are the four and you
will see nothing nothing new here not
meaning that everything is solved here
this is the four main a let's say
algorithm types or algorithm groups
within computer vision that are relevant
in remote sensing segmentation detection
change detection meaning detection plus
looking things over time and regression
okay and this is what you're seeing
there is an actual image of one of the
projects we have this is a large four
station right a in a forest operation
and you're using segmentation to
determine where's the actual forest
worse the actual trees and you can see
those blue lines there a versus where
there's nothing you're using detection
to actually detect the individual trees
and count them we're using change
detection to look at the evolution of
play of harvesting of the different
activities that take place within a four
station and we're using regression to
estimate from the time series of those
trees growing the potential value of all
the four stations single problem we're
using all those algorithms there let's
see some some some more detailed
problems so segmentation this is the
classical one this is the one that
probably a it's been around for a while
since Landsat started sharing their
images a remote sensing community and
some computer scientists started looking
at how to do land-use basically it was
done an image processing huge jump when
machine learning came up and in the last
couple of years as we're having more
data available for companies like us but
a lot of
companies that are following the same
goal you start there's that there's a
boom of this last cvpr
there was a huge challenge on on for
instance on land use which has been a
traditional problem for a while so you
can see here this is Sabadell actually
this is here I try to take pictures a
near Barcelona so and this is a typical
problem of land use which is assigning a
pixel to a type of use or to a type of
cover that land is having be it
different types of forest agriculture
residential buildings industrial
buildings and so forth only doing that
you can do a lot of interesting stuff
segmentation another one here so this is
another problem we are this is an in
this case this is called rapeseed which
is the the crop that is used for canola
oil which is a very it's growing a lot
it's quite good because it's reclaiming
palm oil which is not so good right in
it so it's growing in South America it's
growing in China it's growing mainly in
Canada it's beautiful because it has all
these yellow flowers so it's important
because there's since it's growing so
much the growth of this by the
individual farmers is not the precisely
monitored in many ways and that needs to
be monitored to understand what the
impact of that growth will have on the
market so we're detecting automatically
canola oil from plantations and this is
a very simple it's simple it's not so
simple but it's a solvable a
segmentation problems and you can do
more stuff here what we're doing is
training a neural network what we would
call semantic segmentation instead of
doing it by a simple 0 1 training here
we're training the a neural network for
instance on roads or on rivers so you
have this image here and we want to
isolate buildings and different types of
of crops and as I said land use you know
roads and rivers and that's the risk
what you're seeing there directly is the
response of the train network on roads
here and on rivers over there and you
do more also more more traditional
detection in this case we're detecting
boats in a lake so this is a
recreational area national parks that
want to assess the human use of that
National Park so they can control when
things are going out of hand when
there's too many people they can
restrict the entrance and they can
restrict the usage of the lakes in those
national and recreational parks this
looks like it looks all of these look
straightforward tons of challenges
within each one of these tons of
challenges to be done day so just to
give you an example here we're talking
about a 15 percent error rate that could
be easily taken to 10-5 given more data
but really if you want applications on
this you need to do even better than
that I was mentioning energy production
of energy here what you have is an oil
field and oil fields need to be looked
for many different directions
typically the oil field belongs to the
government and it is a given to
different companies for exploitation so
the government wants to know that that
is done in the right way for instance
from an environmental purpose and each
one of those companies want to
understand each one's operations and
they also want to understand the other
guy's operations right so there's a lot
of information that you can extract and
this is actually you know the response
of things like I showed you that nuraghe
that road train neural network in Pat in
a paddy tech chure and an oil pipe
detection on this particular image that
you see here that's the response there
and that's the actual a ground truth
that we're obtaining as you can imagine
and I'm going to finish with some of the
challenges or top challenges we have but
as you can imagine the difficult chroma
like we say here there is the ground
truth the difficult thing to obtain is
the ground truth so now if you add to
detection you that time you have this
kind of situation this is exactly the
same region right and you can say
okay do a change detection algorithm if
anybody you know for those who here who
are aware of image processing in
computer vision a what you have there in
the middle that's an oil spill and
that's exactly what you want to detect
that's what your system you want to take
one day there's an oil spill you're
looking at the planet and you know
there's an oil spill there and you can
act upon it immediately the problem is
that any traditional change detection of
two images will put will say that those
images are essentially if different on
every single pixel if you look at that
so our challenge was to train detectors
in order to look at at these these are
exactly once again these two images that
you're seeing horizontally are exactly
the same images and the regions that you
see surrounded by red is where we've
seen changes relevant changes so you
would say that semantic change detection
in the sins I don't want to look for
vegetation changes I don't want to look
for seasonal changes because there's a
draught or because it rained right
before an image or any other type I just
want to look where there's new in this
case oil pads or your pools roads in the
other case where there's a new oil spill
or in this case I want to look where
there's harvest there has been
harvesting in forestry and where there
has been deforestation in large forest
this one is a nice one because here what
you're doing is you're training a
classifier on solar panels and this is
related to understanding energy right at
a global scale you're training on a
solar panel and you're actually looking
at the image and the response let's say
to a city of a city or a certain region
to the solar panel detector at two
different times and by subtracting those
you can have those heat maps right away
telling you where there were solar
panels installed in that lapse of time
and you can do it there's many more
examples but I kind of feel attached to
these examples because every time I look
at the images those is exactly the same
into the same place and you see that the
most relevant changes are around even
shadows are a problem here because the
satellites not always take the image or
capture the image from the same angle
it's a very tough problem what you
actually want to say is only show me
only the changes in the building or show
me only where the growth of the river
might pose a problem to a certain type
of infrastructure and that's exactly
what these detectors are finally in
finally regression a I said segmentation
detection change detection and
regression you see here in this
particular case we are in a merging
fusing very different data sources to
estimate soil in rice plant a soil
moisture in rice plantation so soil
moisture is not so easy to detect
because the plant covers the soil in
many cases so you have to look through
the plants so what we're doing is not
only using the visible channels but also
using near-infrared thermal infrared
channels to build these to regress the
amount of soil moisture and if you have
a this is this is the same this is the
soil moisture estimation the water level
indices in the whole plantation and if
if you have in this case what you have
is for a certain or a rice field the
yield that that rice fields had at the
end of a campaign so a rice the
harvesting rice planting campaign can
last about 4 months ok so here you have
regression plus time where you end up
having some kind of predictive analytics
so what I want to be able to do is at
any time of the campaign be able to
predict the actual yield that I will
have because in agriculture a lot of
people move by proxies they're just
saying ok I'm looking at work with the
amount of hydrogen or the amount of
water or fertilizers that I need at the
end of the day because I want more yield
so if we're able to look at the actual
yield because we're
to capture that information in week
after week predicting yield based on
current situations every week we can act
on our plantation not based on the water
level that is important but not the only
thing but based on the actual yield same
thing in this case we applied this thing
for a estimating future forest density
so with that I showed you I hope you
know some good examples of computer
vision applied to these types of images
across many fields and I mentioned that
in this case this is a solution that is
being developed of transforming these
computer vision results into an alert
engine for operators of oil pipelines
and you can have this kind of things
across infrastructure as I said Kisuke
managed roads and bridges and power
plants and so forth energy food security
and also natural resources governments
into cartography policy and government
you wouldn't imagine because we're used
to Google Maps and we're used to open
street maps and those are great were
there's people but there's not people
you know most of the earth there's no
people and they're really bad you
wouldn't imagine how bad the
cartographic status of certain regions
of the planet is today and in order to
start understanding once again what we
need to do with the planet you need to
get that right from the beginning so I
want to finish by especially because
this is a technical community to have
pealing - the technical skills and
basically sharing with you that were far
from having this problem solved so I
chose a single problem a single sector
let's say which is the ad tech you know
technology applied to agriculture sector
and the the kind of Holy Grail in
agriculture is what you see there that
tractor who's being told directly from
the satellite the percentages of
whatever seeds or fertilizer or water
off whatever needs to apply to be
applied in order to rationalize the use
of resources in order to optimize the
productivity okay and that's that would
allow what I said at the very beginning
to have a much better use of current
resources without depleting you know the
jungle or the desert right but even
doing things here is very tough and let
me let me show you first of all there's
a lot of variability between crops you
you work for for for three months in
order to do this great thing about soy
and so much or rice moisture that I show
it won't work with wheat right it won't
it has absolutely nothing to do but then
you have it won't even work with with
the same a crop in a different region so
you have rice in Argentina and you have
rice in China whole different story
different soil so you have to do it all
over again think from it as a
machine-learning expert the ground truth
that you need you need that ground truth
all over again in many place and then it
doesn't work on the same crop on the
same land because you have generic
variety and I might have this field here
that comes out of certain variety of
rice in the field next door is a
different variety of rice so if I train
a model on this field here it just won't
work on the field next to its same soil
same crop then of course it won't work
between different campaigns because I
have same soil same crop same field next
campaign next year first day rains a lot
everything's risk different from the
rest of whatever I inferred on the
previous campaign won't work on this one
and on top of that you have regulations
so across countries you might have that
certain types of fertilizers that
certain types of seeds are allowed and
not so the kind of measures that you can
prescript
in one place or the other will
completely different and that's only the
variability issue in terms of learning
there's also the availability and the
typical lack of availability that we
will find in many fields is lack of
ground truth the lack of digitized data
and the truth is that in many sectors
you know the farmers are still writing
them down in notebooks their
observations everything they write down
but in notebook so there's low levels of
digitization and availability in this
particular field is also low because
it's it's learning cycle it takes a year
it's not like the Drosophila right like
that you can do to your genetic advance
was really fast because of the
generations this takes a year you know
so you need to test whatever you learn
next year and on top of that this is one
you know this is a kind of thing where
startups are crashing like bugs against
the light you know that you can see
attics startups a starting and ending
their lives every single day because
they don't realize these kind of things
for instance a the genetic lifespan of a
certain crop variety the average is 3
years today so if I'm planting wheat the
probability in five years that the seeds
the genetic variety of the wheat I
planted today is similar is is very very
low okay so that means that imagine
first from a machine-learning
perspective first campaign you have no
idea it's a new genetic variety so you
try to gather all the data you have
second one you have one data point and
the third one you have two data points
hopefully you're able to predict
something and the next one there's a
different genetic variety so there goes
all you and on top of that you have new
sensors I mentioned that hyperspectral
sensor it's very exciting a say okay we
have hyperspectral data but we don't
have hyper spectral ground truth so how
do we infer from the ground truth we
have that is measured that is captured
with other sensors and of course all the
things we're doing are very nice and on
top of all those things we need to
provide information to the farmers in a
real-time so here's there's many
but these are the three most relevant
lines of research that are pretty hot
today that are very relevant for what I
do
number one is automated data generation
okay I don't need to wait for the farmer
for the whole year you know I need to be
able to simulate all these cycles I need
need to be able to simulate the the
behavior of the genetic varieties I need
to be able to simulate and get data even
if it's not exactly the data that I need
in order to train the models that I need
one-shot learning very important because
of all the examples that I gave you this
is kind of self-explanatory and with one
that I believe is huge is of course
transfer learning and domain adaptation
for instance if you look at regions like
Europe like in Spain were very advanced
in terms of olive trees right and we
have pretty much a good idea especially
in where there's expensive production
high-value production we probably have a
name and last name for every single
olive tree over there right and we have
a lot of data points for the olive trees
and there's a lot of investment in
gathering data but then you go to the
olive tree production in Morocco and you
have no idea okay so maybe this kind of
satellite data that you can have cheap
or almost free in both Spain and Morocco
can be a great transfer medium for all
the things that you are able to learn
with algorithms in Spain and apply in
Morocco so domain adaptation for places
from MU you know moving from places
where you have a lot of ground truth
data available to places where you don't
have ground truth available especially
because this typically agrees with
places that you have high levels of
development to places where you have low
levels of development will be huge and
there is a very classical machine
learning and computer vision problem so
with these challenges I wanted to finish
and invite you to to ask questions and
if don't worry we'll take a couple and
and we'll go afterwards outside for if
there's anybody who wants to chat a
little bit more about these challenges
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much very interesting
could you speak about data volumes and
data stack to be able to achieve that
something that we that you're dealing
with I didn't get the last part you
mentioned about data stack data stack
like are you using a Hadoop cluster to
process the data or are you using other
technologies yes and data volumes are
you dealing with a very big data sets or
yes how does it work in that specific
space yes yes I wanted you know we had a
discussion about Peter at the beginning
I wanted the presentation here to focus
more on the challenges and the work
that's being done I have another
presentation that was presented a while
ago and data beers they had more to do
about the challenges due to the volumes
of data because here we're talking
petabytes let's say just the earth at
one meter resolution is half a bit about
the day okay so so there's a lot to be
done there the interesting thing is also
here that you have different communities
that have developed different platforms
that are relevant for us of course you
have the typical data stacks of the big
data can be the traditional stacks that
you're talking about of the big data
community but this is per very
particular data because it's geo
localized data so there's some things
that are easier in the sense for
instance if you have multiple data
sources it's pretty straightforward how
you stack them one on top of the other
in order to have all the information
because they refer to a particular point
so there's a lot of work related to that
to managing geographic information that
has been developed for searching in
geographic information like post Chris a
G's a specialized for geographic
information system that has been
developed in the G is a community and
then you have all the more machine
learning let's say a tools what we found
from the beginning is that we would have
to develop and I think that the
different companies that are dealing
with them with this are pretty much in
the same situation with
what I've spoken with him we have had to
develop our own a stack for dealing with
this
so basically we're working of course on
on cloud because this is you you cannot
work locally with this kind of
information and and then the rest you
know we're using most of the development
we're doing is basically pure Python and
on top of that we're using the
traditional libraries both for for a
handling large amounts of data and for
handling geographic information data
from from from the Python library so
we're developing it ourselves
we're happy to to show you the the
details of the platform if you're
interested outside yes
right you showed this soil moisture
modeling which I thought very
interesting on it I'm working undirected
I heard you before better than now with
a micro okay I know so you showed this
soil moisture modeling and do you have
also modeled smell like penetration of
this water to lower areas within the
soil or a we don't right now there are a
lot of models for this a once again a
ground truth gets you really far and in
certain places of the world there's
amazing to a lot models of geological
formation that go a so you can mix that
in order to infer water penetration
models there's a lot of there's not too
much work done on the there's a lot of
work done here from the more physical
standpoint from the traditional remote
sensing or geological the communities
not much merging this with new machine
learning techniques so there's a bunch
of opportunities to do interesting
things there from a remote sensing
perspective a it's very difficult to do
this you would need a go to go with
sensors that go completely either fully
into the infrared or into the
ultraviolet and there are these sensors
but in many cases these sensors are
expensive and still not validated in
terms of accuracy so we're not using
that but but already by merging this
with existing geological information
there's a lot still to be done
you